can you explain why stoicism is having
such
modern day popularity at the moment it's
not like i'm seeing
tons of people turning to taoism or
confucianism
but stoicism is like the hot new girl in
school at the moment
yeah i don't i don't know exactly why
that is it's been an interesting journey
i mean i've been writing about stoicism
for
almost 15 years so i i even
in my own time writing about it i've
seen some sort of peaks and valleys but
i i i think ultimately it comes down to
stoicism as a philosophy
designed both around and for
dealing with adversity so i don't think
it should surprise us that
that it it it tends to pop back up when
you know things are difficult i mean
marcus aurelius is writing meditations
during the antonine plague
so the idea that you know it would have
something to teach us during
you know the covid19 pandemic i don't
think should be that surprising
[Music]
you're totally right it does read very
modern
why is it that stoicism reads like it
was written two weeks ago and not two
millennia ago
well even even when you think about
how marcus aurelius is writing so he's
writing during the antonine plague
but but his book meditations it
translates he was writing in greek
uh instead of the less formal latin and
and he was writing
it the title of it translates to himself
right so he was writing his book to
himself it wasn't ever intended for
publication
and and even seneca's writing was
probably the most accessible
of the stoics you know a good chunk of
it survives to us
in the form of letters he was writing to
his friend
letters of a stoic letters from a stoic
it's really
seneca writing to his friend lucillus
and so if
if we can think of the literary
implications of that that
instead of trying to sort of get down
this brilliant
theory or to perfectly craft their words
in such a way
that it's accessible and and i
that's what i love about the stokes is
that again it's not a collection of
theories it's just
you know real people talking about real
problems and
and as it happens the problems of the
ancient world
although unique in many ways we're not
that different than the problems we have
today like
people are people we get jealous we
you know we have urges you know we have
ambitions we make mistakes
you know people are people i understand
that yeah
i did some research in the time that
most of the stoics were alive
the entire global population was
somewhere between 150
and 330 million people so at most
it was like the same as today's
population of the united states
given that there's so many more people
alive today why
why aren't we finding an epictetus in
every country have all of the struggles
of
how to live been worked out or is no one
asking the right questions anymore
no i mean what's interesting yeah you're
right that that's the global population
but
you know a a very large chunk of even
that population
rest rested inside the roman empire
you know you you can you can uh you can
make this you go oh the stoics were dead
white guys but what's to me so
fascinating is
is just how diverse you know they were
obviously there were some female strokes
but
you know seneca is from spain there were
stoics from modern-day turkey and iraq
and you know greece and all over the the
the roman world so i don't think it's
that uh you know why haven't we
covered you know uncovered any more
stoics
um i think it's more like you know the
stoics are basically saying that that
history is this sort of
loop on repeat and so if if we get the
sense that
what was happening in the ancient world
is is the same as what's happening
today and that it's the same thing over
and over again it sort of helps explain
why it doesn't feel like there's any
this
some new exciting voice i mean you have
epictetus who's a slave who
has his legs broken who's clapped in
irons
and then you know in nineteen
1964 1965 james stockdale shot down over
vietnam
a fan of epictetus he actually is
repeating epictetus to himself as he's
you know heading down into this camp has
his leg broken
you know is clapton irons comes to a lot
of the same conclusions as epictetus did
so
in in that sense like uh you know i
think it sort of confirms the idea that
that
you know again people are people in
history is history
what was the unique insight that we had
in ancient rome and ancient athens
well i mean i think that the core
premise of stoicism is basically look we
don't control the world around us but we
control how we respond
and and that that seems very common
sensical
but if you actually look at how most
people
go through their lives we spend an
inordinate amount of time focusing on
stuff that's not on our control and
i i did this this morning i got off the
call i was on a conference call with
someone i got off and
you know the first thing i did was call
this other person we complained about
how
ridiculous the other person was being
and it's like what a colossal waste of
of both of our times you know instead of
focusing on what we're going to do about
it
you know we did the easier thing which
is try to blame or whine or
you know it's it's uh just like people
wake up and they're upset that it's
raining
you know and the stokes would say it's
raining what do you you know
what are you gonna do about it new book
lives of the stoics the art of living
from zeno to marcus aurelius why did you
write this
well i i've written a lot about stoicism
and i've written a lot about what the
stoics have said i've tried to
illustrate these ideas
in the past through you know through
stories from
sports and and history and war and
business but but i really wanted to
and and there it hasn't existed and so
that's why i decided to do it
the actual stoics themselves have always
been
kind of a mystery they're they're you
know they they were not
super famous in their own time so a lot
of conflicting sources
and sort of all you know there's a
little bit here and a little bit there
and so what i wanted to do is create
as as i've you know been lucky enough to
help popularize stoicism
people go oh but who were these people
and so i wanted to write a book that
really
puts like sort of uh you know
not faces to the name but but puts
events
to the name and the face and and you
know at the core of it stoicism is
supposed to be a philosophy that you do
not something you say and so i i was
also really fascinated with and i remain
fascinated with especially with someone
like seneca
you know is it is it actually possible
to live up to this standard and how does
a human
you know fair trying to actually live
by these teachings you know it says
something about where philosophy is
today that
you know does anyone care what the life
of a harvard
you know philosophy professor looks like
no because we've kind of made this
this this allowance that philosophy is
the theory
and then the person's life is irrelevant
but in the ancient world that was just
not how it was
yeah i totally get that man the the
armchair philosophizing
unfortunately appears to be a little bit
of a curse especially in the modern
world
everyone has that friend that loves to
talk a good game
he loves to always be honoured talking
about their plans this is what i've got
coming up
and then never ever uh gets skin in the
game
and actually goes and does it certainly
i'd agree reading about
the ancient stoics in real life seems to
give some
extra depth to them and the historical
context
do you think that sort of helps us to
understand some of the lessons that they
taught by
understanding that broader environment i
i think so and look i think there's
another part it's not just like hey
you can talk to the game but did you
live it but also like
if you live a boring sheltered
you know false life you know
uh how could you possibly understand
what the world is and possibly teach or
explain
anything to people who
uh are out doing those things right so
um you know t lawrence talks about this
where
he he he's saying like no to to
translate the odyssey you have to have
actually traveled you have to have led
men into battle you know
you have to have experienced some of the
deprivations that odysseus went through
and so i think one of the things that's
most compelling to me about
the stoics even when they were somewhat
hypocritical even when they fell short
there's not a there's not a single stoic
in the book
that did not live an interesting life
right
and and and that's that's not just
me choosing who i wanted to put in i
mean there were a few boring stoics that
you know um or only boring only what's
boring as far as what we know about them
that i didn't include
but but for the most part every one of
them was a soldier or a diplomat
or a you know an artist or a world
leader
or um a business person or you know
what's what i love about the stokes is
that they were there when it was
happening
right they were there as rome was being
overthrown
and the republic transitions into you
know an empire
they were there at the assassination of
julius caesar
they were at they were at octavian who
succeeds uh julius caesar's
you know right hand they were literally
advising him and then this goes all the
way on down to marcus aurelius who was
literally running the known world and
being a philosopher you know so i again
i just contrast this to
you know i get the purpose of
academic tenure but i i
somewhat reject the idea that someone
who has job security for life
can tell me a person who does not have
that
how the world works that's a great point
i have to say i'm quite wistful for the
ancient world
when reading this book it seems like
ancient athens and rome would have been
a
wonderful place to have lived as an
aspiring philosopher for instance you
got that
story of clianthes getting a round of
applause from the crowd around him
because he wasn't phased by an insult
from some playwright on stage which just
seems like the opposite of the
pop mob culture that we've got now or
other things like like the prominent
sort of master slave relationships
to me would just be prime tools for
identifying themes in human behavior
how much do you think that the culture
of the ancient world
helped to foster this environment of
where philosophers could learn and
thrive is there anything else you know
you've got these plagues going on you've
got the
overtaking of different countries and
falls of the roman empire
that must have must have been a
beautiful breeding ground for it
yeah i mean look i'm i'm endlessly
fascinated with greece and rome and
and and like you know i can go to rome
or greece and
imagine myself there and and i i love it
and then and then i also have to remind
myself like
as bad as things are in this moment like
they would kill to be alive today you
know like
like covet 19 is is absolutely nothing
compared
to the antonine plate which killed
millions of people it lasted for 15
years
you know it it it caused all sorts of
civil unrest it was a disaster of epic
proportions and
and like i think that's one of the
problems too with history like when we
read history we go oh i would have been
you know a senator you know alongside
julius caesar and maybe i would have
i would have helped in the assassination
or you know i would have
i would have no like at best we would
have been
like a slave like epictetus you know
like the vast
the vast vast vast majority of people
led you know brutish brutus
sorry brutish and short and nasty lives
you know they were the litter carriers
and they were the they were
you know they were digging horrible
minds and and
uh you know dying of the plague or you
know they were
they were being sold into slavery or you
know thrown
against a wall of barbarians in some
horrible war
um or just you know died from getting
their finger cut
because we didn't have antibiotics to
fight infections you know like
it i i do as much as i am fascinated by
the ancient world i i try
also to to sort of
feel grateful for the incredible like
you know sort of pleasures and gifts and
and luxuries that we have today
you're right we can romanticize all we
want about the ancient world but it's
been cleaned up since then
so i spent my birthday this year uh
at the stowapo like i actually was there
like birthplace of stoicism beautiful
it's i'm sure that you have
seen it and it's beautiful and clean and
it is wonderful the weather was great
and i went for a coffee and
you're totally right looking at it in
this very
rose tinted glasses uh view is nothing
like what the world would have been then
um i mean it's like why did they have
the plague why did these diseases spread
it's because
people [ __ ] in the streets and and they
were you know
like uh you know that it was it was
like actually i opened stillness uh
you know stillness is the key with this
sort of story that seneca writes in one
of his letters you know he's
sitting in this sort of apartment in
rome and he's trying to write
and he's just describing like the worst
noise you can imagine right like noise
that would make new york city seem
quiet and so that's the other thing is
like yeah when we walk these city
streets there
they're they're empty and cleaned up and
and
and and preserved and you see these
ruins what you don't
you don't get this you don't get the
sense of the grime and the
dirt and the and the the animals and the
you know like the the the just
i mean just imagine f like if the
population of rome is 50 million
and 5 million people dying like just
imagine
one in 10 million people dying uh
we're having trouble in the united
states like
they're having to bring in freezer
trucks for the bodies from from the
coronavirus pandemic
imagine imagine what they had to do then
and actually
that's one of uh i don't know if you've
had donald robertson on but he wrote
this great book about marcus aurelius
recently
uh and and he describes and i i rely on
it in lives of the stokes but
he sort of in rome during the antonine
plague they thought that
incense could ward off the
the the spread of the plague and so rome
was this
this this smell of like putrid bodies
and
incense and then you can imagine the
heat with
and no air conditioning and ventilation
i mean it would have been
the stench would have been overwhelming
and so
you know it's it's fascinating and
endlessly
you know intriguing but i think we we we
have to remember and this is something i
try to remind myself
too you know when people say oh aren't
you picking and choosing from the
philosophy
i mean these are people that did not
understand biology these are people that
had no understanding of psychology
you know these like in some respects
they were so
far ahead of their time and then in
other respects were
were you know primitive really and and
so
it's a it's just a a unique situation to
be sure
wasn't it aristotle that thought the
only purpose of the brain was to get rid
of heat out of the body
i mean seneca in one of his things he's
you know he's sort of
uh he you know he goes into this big
defense on on
on bloodletting like on how you you know
you cure diseases by
you know cutting people open and letting
them bleed which
which was stupid then
but but like people continued to do for
another
1800 or so years right like when you
just
when you realize like how i think that's
the other thing
we have trouble just even wrapping
around wrapping our heads around
how new found a lot of the progress that
we have like we don't
as human beings we don't often sells
give often
give ourselves credit for just how
recently we've pulled ourselves out of
this muck so to speak
i agree so we're going to play a game
it's top of the
top of the pops ryan holidays stoic
philosopher edition
okay what i want you to do is give us
your top three favorite characters
featured in the book and a lesson or a
story from each which explains why
you're such a fan of them
all right um i'll give you i'll give you
so marcus aurelius is my favorite of
course
uh which should i go in from top to
bottom or bottom to top oh
uh oh well yeah let's go let's we'll
work reverse we'll work in reverse okay
um so so for if we're going from from
reverse
uh so let's start with zeno the founder
of stoicism
uh again uh for people who don't think
this is modern i mean
he's a merchant and he's leading a
convoy of ships filled with dye and he
suffers a shipwreck in a storm
and loses everything and you might think
this is the worst thing that ever
happened to him but in fact the disaster
is what leads him to athens
where he discovers philosophy and then
ends up founding stoicism and his quip
about this was
you know fortune uh gave me a great
fortune by
you know destroying my fortune or he
says you know i suffered a great
uh you know a great gift by this
shipwreck his point being
the worst thing that ever happened to
him was actually the best thing that
ever happened to him and so
you know i think it's quite fitting that
stoicism would be
founded you know in a moment of extreme
adversity and as a writer
you know i love the idea that he's
introduced to philosophy
in a bookstore in athens so cool um yeah
it's amazing so
the the next one would be rutilius rufus
who is uh
you know not a particularly well-known
stoic um
but but someone i ended up wanting to
focus on he's a
like sort of an administrator he's like
the equivalent of a governor uh in
united states terms
uh but but maybe actually more of it he
he's
he's the governor of a colony right so
this would be uh you know he's he's
uh often one of the far-flung provinces
and he begins to
institute a whole bunch of reforms
and these reforms are designed to
prevent the romans
from you know essentially looting the
provinces
right you know obviously this is this is
the history of the sort of the british
empire right it's like
you know these far-flung outpostings the
business people come in
and they they they sort of bring home
enormous fortunes but at the grave
expense of the
the people there and so rotilia starts
to institute just some like pretty basic
you know reforms nothing radical um but
but you can imagine even this tiny bit
of
fair dealing is cutting into the profits
of the you know the robber barons making
their fortunes there
and so that uh and and i think this this
uh
has some similarities to our uh you know
our moment today
so so what do they do they bring him up
on charges of corruption right
he's sort of trumped up charges of of
corruption he's forced to defend himself
but he refuses he's he knows he's
totally innocent he knows as a complete
farce
so he refuses to offer even one uh you
know one word
in his own defense uh sort of just
stoically takes the the injustice
and so at the end the pronouncement is
that his property is to be confiscated
and he is to be exiled
and the one bit of clemency or mercy
that the judge
offers uh is that he can choose where he
will go
into exile and so he chooses to go
back to the colony that he had been
uh been been accused of stealing from
and that colony knowing that he is
innocent uh receives him with open arms
and offers him
honorary citizenship and he actually
never returns to rome
and so i just i love the idea of kind of
the last honest man
uh you know the the even in times of
corruption endemic corruption
and crime and and avarice you have sort
of one stoic figure sort of above the
fray
doing the right thing um and and and
and you know we have this idea that
you'll be rewarded for doing the right
thing and unfortunately that's not often
how it goes and then the final uh one i
would do i would do marcus
i realized just because he's my favorite
and i think sort of the penultimate
example of stoicism
but in the darkest days of the antonine
plague
uh you know there there's uh tribes have
rev
rebelled at the border uh there's an
invasion
uh there you know it's it's as bad as it
can get rome is
is essentially bankrupt uh and and what
does marcus do
i mean we know what people with absolute
power do is they
they make it somebody else's problem
right they they invade someone
or they plunder something or they you
know they kick the can down the road or
they levy high
you know unpayable taxes whatever it is
marcus instead
goes through the palace and selects the
finest of the imperial treasures
and he sells them on the lawn of the
palace
paying down rome's debt with the
treasures that he has no use for
could you imagine um donald trump doing
a car boot sale on the front lawn of the
white house
just selling a pen here's a pen here's a
daughter do you want a daughter i've got
a daughter to give away
it's it's it's so funny because like in
in a sense
trump is the opposite of marcus aurelius
in literally every way
and it's like not only can you not
imagine him doing that
he's doing all the things that i said
you know what do people with power do
right
people with power don't take
responsibility people with power
you know force the suffering upon you
know the most
vulnerable in society because they have
the you know the least amount of
influence
right they they uh they run up huge
bills that somebody else has to pay they
they suffer well you know they don't
suffer well they they eat well well
everyone suffers so on and so forth
and so yeah i think you know marcus
aurelius in that plague is sort of the
a paragon of of what leadership
in turbulent times is supposed to look
like i love that man i really do
which stoic do you think struggled the
most with
living their work stoicism as you've
said it's a
philosophy of action it's one that you
don't just learn you have to live it
is there someone who is particularly
defeated by vices in real life
well sure i mean i talk about a stoic
named diotimus who sort of is guilty of
this kind of literary crime
but but and and so there's some failures
like that but i think
seneca is kind of the ultimate example
of the tension of
a worldly philosophy because here you
have this guy who writes these
beautiful letters about virtue and about
courage and about moderation
and then you know he works for nero
he's nero's top advisor and you know he
throws these gatsby-esque parties and
he's one of the richest men in rome
and so it's this question of you know is
he a massive hypocrite
or is it more complicated than that you
know uh is he
working for nero because you know he
doesn't believe
any of the things that he's written
about or is it that
you know he feels that in working for
nero he is containing nero's worst
impulses
you know so much of this is obviously
unknowable
but i think seneca of all the stoics
raises the most interesting questions
yeah you mentioned that apart from
epictetus most of the stoics were rich
or
famous or powerful why were rich men
talking about resilience is it just
armchair philosophizing about
problems that they had the luxury not to
encounter
i mean uh maybe a little bit i mean look
even the richest man in rome would have
had to be far more resilient than
probably your average
person in two days yeah you're right i
mean like
if marcus aurelius wanted to read at
night
that was a big operation that that
involves
torches and slaves and you know
unrolling scrolls
of writing and you know like open the
kindle up and crack on
yeah i mean warren buffett has talked
about this he's like look like
a poor person today is warm during the
winter and cold during the summer
you know that's something that louis xiv
couldn't have said right
um so so i think resilience was a real
fact of life and
and as rich as they were most of them
were at the whims of
uh you know of a seneca is working for
nero but he's
you know he's he's riding the tigers
back there i mean ultimately he's killed
by nero
right so these are capricious uncertain
chaotic times
even for the rich and privileged um so i
think that's part of it
um i think the other part of it is you
know
uh the when the stoics are talking about
resiliency
that or freedom even you know they're
talking about
that not just literally but also
figuratively
so you know epictetus is watching these
incredibly rich people in nero service
you know kissing the feet of this madman
and you know forced to put on elaborate
parties and events like
it was a it's not that it was a grind in
the way that working in a
you know in a diamond mine is a grind
but it was a grind in that
you know uh nobody was actually free to
be who they wanted to be
so they're you know it was privileged
relatively but also you know uh by no
means an easy life
i mean look at the sycophantic inner
circle that
adolf hitler had of course sure
and that and that same thing that is the
that is the norm not the exception
for absolute rulers yeah
yeah it's i the thing that strikes me is
so interesting about stoicism are these
universal truths about how to live a
good life
right the fact that kind of the same as
mathematics
there's this knowledge which is
to be discovered somehow and there's
this universal
thread that ties all humans together
and the fact that you can go from a
pre-christ era where as you say there's
people dying in the streets and we think
that
trapanning will help to relieve a
headache or that the brain is getting
rid of heat out of the body
all the way up to the 21st century where
we're consuming the world news in
immediate time and flying off into space
and yet the challenges that we face are
still the same ones
well what i'm what i'm fascinated by is
seneca and jesus are born in the same
year
in different provinces of the same
empire
and are walking around for a good chunk
of their lives
you know in the same planet in the same
universe i mean
seneca's brother is in the bible so
the idea that you know
that that that this wisdom is somehow
just the word of god it's it's what i
love is like
you know there are quotes that come out
of marcus realist that
you sound like they should be in the
bible just as there's just as there's
quote you know ecclesiastes and marcus
really sound
very similar at times and but by the
same token
there are also things that confucius
said centuries before marcus or stoicism
was was you know was was even a thought
and and that sounds really similar so
you know i think i sort of liken it
because i i did end up exploring this in
in my book on stillness but but i think
what it is is like
when you're responding to the same
fundamental problems
there's only so many solutions right and
and
i sort of liken it from an evolutionary
standpoint like
we're just evolving similar adaptations
we might come from different ancestors
but but you know flying makes sense
right or an opposable thumb makes sense
or eyesight it makes
sense right and you could see why from
different sources you could get
somewhere
close to the same outcome we've been
asking these questions for a long time
and yeah i think the lindy effect which
everyone who's listening should be
familiar with but if you're not it's the
uh lifespan of a non-perishable good so
for instance an idea
and the presumption is that newer is
always better i think a lot of people in
the modern era get seduced by that
right you have the the the newest this
thing
i think the newest iphone is different
but has uh trickled down
to well this book is more recent
therefore it should be better
but the classics of the classics for a
reason i can't remember who it was it
might be i might even be quoting you
back to yourself here
but that you would sooner read the
hundred best books a thousand times
than read a hundred thousand books
that that quote's definitely not me but
i agree with
take it right take it you can have that
one that'll be yours
well no i i mean look i think about that
because look when i
when i set out you know almost 10 years
ago now to write my first book on
stoicism
and i i was actually just i had uh my
editor at portfolio penguin
on my podcast and i was like what did
you think when i came to you with this
book proposal about a book about
you know an obscure school of ancient
philosophy and she was like
honestly your marketing books had done
well and so
we were thinking well maybe he'll just
get this
out of his it won't do well
and then he'll go back to his other
stuff and
and the reason why i knew better and i
knew differently
is that this stuff had a 2
000 year track record you know or a 2
500 year track record almost
so i think what the lindy effect helps
you with and i
it's a it's a concept i'm very familiar
with and very fond of
what the lindy effect does is
essentially vet things for you
so you know if i had come up with some
totally new philosophy
that was but at its core identical to
stoicism
you would have no idea it you know you'd
be like you'd have to take my word for
it right it's like
you know i'm giving you these are the
virtues is the stuff you know you'd have
to hope that
either i'd have to be a very seductive
you know compelling writer
or you know you'd have to be very
gullible to to take that seriously
but when i when i say hey look this
isn't me
this is me you know slightly updating or
organized like
my book uh the daily stoic is not me
coming up with principles of stoicism
it's just i said hey wouldn't it be
convenient if there was a way to just
read one quote from the stoics every day
so the reason that book worked is that
you know
obviously there was some sort of
organizational innovation there
but uh the reason that book is sold a
million copies is because
uh it was vetted by millions of people
for
2500 years and and
and those weren't even ordinary people
right like like marcus aurelius is
stress testing these ideas at like
the absolute testing point of the human
experience like
you know he's not like oh yeah this held
up pretty well at my job at
you know uh this toll booth or something
right
you know he's he's running an empire of
50 million people and he's given
absolute power and so if the ideas don't
work
there and if they don't work in the
laboratory of
of epictetus experience you know
uh we'd have we'd have known about that
it's like the
equivalent of evolution right the good
it's a tim ferrissism the good [ __ ]
sticks
yeah and one of the things david perrell
passed modern wisdom guest and good
buddy
he has this really interesting insight
where he talks about the vast majority
of the content that people now consume
has been created within the last
24 hours it's like we have a society
which is wrapped around being anti-lindy
that's totally right and and i did a
piece about this a while ago i said look
like
if if you want to if you want to
understand what's happening in the world
you got to stop watching the news and
you got to start reading books like
if you want to understand like the
geopolitical jockeying between say
america and china like
you should study the jockeying between
athens and sparta the ascendant empire
and the declining empire
you know if you want to understand you
know russia today
look at russia a thousand years ago and
you'll
it because people are people you know
cultures or cultures
and i think people are
you know like for instance in in the
united states we're having a reckoning
over race
and a lot of people are rushing out to
buy these books by these gurus you know
whether it's white fragility or
whatever and it's like these are
management consultants
you know putting in our books to
capitalize on a trend
meanwhile you know ralph ellison's
invisible man is one of the greatest
novels ever written you know james
baldwin is one of the greatest writers
who ever lived
um you know you can you can read
frederick douglass you know you can you
can go
directly to the source in a lot of these
instances
uh and and learn so much more and most
importantly
it's stripped of the modern assumptions
or biases or
interpretations or speculation and and
so like
that's uh what i often tell people the
role of my books
are my books are to you know capture
someone's interest
and hopefully the next book they read
after mine
is something from the you know from the
original canon
and and uh and so
like i i take almost as as much pride in
how my books have done as i do you know
why every every
you know few months there's some trend
piece about the sales of the
of the ancient stoic techs and having
you know seen
i watch a lot of those sales come
through my websites and links that i put
out
i know that what i'm ultimately doing
with the real important
contribution that i'm making is driving
people to
the classic text which is you know in a
sense me paying forward the
you know the break that i got when
someone did that for me it's a shame
that
uh marcus aurelius can't get you on an
affiliate deal you know that would be
if you were the the lead magnet for
marcus aurelius he'd be you'd be
both be laughing it'd be brilliant i
mean i i more think about
i wish that someone that that i'd been
on a track where i could have learned
greek or latin and then done the
translations myself
you know um are you tempted by that i
mean
am i tempted in my 30s to learn greek or
latin and
and become a classic scholar not as much
uh it's a fantasy sure
what do you think the ancient stoics
would be most
and least proud of about modern society
we're talking about how
those ideas now map on to our ex
experience today
well you know i was i was uh i was
been fascinated in writing a lot i think
early on my writing about the stoics was
primarily about
the resiliency we talked about
productivity about success about
you know self-discipline but you know
there's probably no concept that mark
surely
talks about more than justice you know
he he refers to the idea of the common
good
something like 40 or 50 times in
meditations
and i was rereading uh
one of the here let me see let me
actually see if i can find it i'll read
it it's pretty beautiful
uh he's thinking sextus
uh okay uh sorry he's thanking his
brother severus who's not really his
brother just a friend
he says uh to love my family truth and
justice
it was through severus that i
encountered thracia helvidius cato dion
and brutus
and conceived of the society of equal
laws governed by equality of status and
speech
and of rulers who respect the liberty of
their subjects above
all else and so obviously a bunch of
those names are people i profile in
lives but
the the the idea that you know what
marcus
marcus's idea of justice and equality
and freedom
and a ruler that respects you know their
subjects
you know that was an idea only in its
infancy just in
you know thomas jefferson is writing
about
you know that all men are created equal
but but it's only the subsequent
generations that manage to get even
remotely close to realizing that idea
so i'd like to think that the stoics
would be you know
impressed and encouraged by
our ability you know our ability to get
from where they were
to where we are now you know seneca
talks about slavery and
zeno talk about slavery and although
they sort of accept it as a
as a you know an assumption of their
time
they're by no means making the sort of
defenses of slavery that even aristotle
is making
and so i'd like to think that from the
the stoics would be
impressed in with our sort of progress
you know they'd probably be uh
disappointed
conversely with our you know that 60
of america is obese you know that uh you
know what percentage of marriage is
ended in divorce and
you know not they wouldn't be looking at
these things from
uh you know the perspective of like sin
and the way that a christian you know if
you if you pulled saint augustine from
around the same time and brought him to
today i think the stoics
you know had this this key virtue of
moderation and self-discipline
and i think it's our abundance and our
you know our our uh the bounty of the
modern world
that they would be disappointed in our
inability to
manage absolutely it's a naval
ravicantism where he says
that all of our problems in the modern
world are problems of abundance and not
scarcity
yes it's bizarre that
for almost all of our evolution we
wanted more than we had
so it's kind of not that surprising that
when we have more than we need
we're going to binge um i know the
stoics were very anti-information
overload as well weren't they and
i think they'd probably have a lot to
say about us spending
five plus hours per day connected to the
rest of the world through a device in
our pocket
yeah i mean marcus realized they'd
probably say like look like i managed to
run an empire of 50 million people
you know through through couriers who
the
papyrus yeah exactly it was weeks after
it had happened
you know uh yeah the
the idea that you need this real time
breaking information when you're not a
head of state
or running a hedge fund you know and i
obviously i talk about this in my first
book my book on media but like
you know what are you doing with this
information you're not doing anything
it's just trivia
you know it's just uh it is trivia in
the same way that you
you know you don't need to eat that bag
of cheetos you don't need to watch msnbc
tonight
but you do it because like i was
thinking about this
today like like uh why am i gonna watch
the presidential debates like
because i'm not a shitty person i
already know who i'm going to vote for
and uh why would i po like
why would i consume this mediocre
entertainment
what do you disagree with about stoicism
yeah it's a it's a good question um i
mean look this i think the stoics have a
somewhat conflicted on this idea of
pre-determination for instance you know
like uh they're they're i think i think
the stoics
because of the world that they lived in
had
a much had a very
realistic uh pessimism about human
agency
right although marcus really does say if
it's humanly possible you can do it so
and so forth
i find it illustrative that epithetis
the slave doesn't say anything about
slavery
you know what i mean like even he
doesn't question
the moral legitimacy of slavery because
it's so
ingrained just seeing it as an immutable
part of
human life yeah yeah and and look right
he's just sort of chosen for it and then
and then he doesn't see like even as his
son
is drifting towards taking over and is
sort of proving himself to be inept
it like it doesn't occur to marcus
aurelius that he can do anything about
it you know so
i think the human agency is something
that i would i would probably
ultimately disagree with on the stoics
and but but i
you know i credit that so that the
progress we've made as a human species
like
you i don't think they quite believed in
human dynamism
in the in the benefits of a dynamic
fluid society of a meritocracy
you know these were things that you know
in england you know they didn't even
fully understand until you know probably
the second world war right like
we we just we we had some unquestioned
beliefs about how society should be
organized just as we have them today and
are
you know sort of struggling to wrap our
heads around them but but i think that
would certainly be a
an area for improvement for them yeah
for sure do you see
stoicism as a spiritual practice
i mean is it a religion no and i like
that about it you know i like that the
stoics aren't saying god
you know said this is true therefore you
should believe it
but but i do think there is something
deeply spiritual about it and i think
i think honestly if you study anything
enough it takes on a kind of
a ritual and a and a profundity so
i think you you get out of it what you
put in it if you read it once
it's not going to be a particularly
spiritual experience but
you know if it's something you really
turn yourself over to i think you'll be
immensely rewarded
i like that i like the fact that if you
dedicate your interest your curiosity
to anything you know you find people who
find gardening to be like almost
spiritual you know it's like you're
planting plants they're not even
conscious
physics can be spiritual you know what i
mean uh and and
and religion can be very unspiritual it
can become
rote and you know traditional
and yeah it or you could do it for some
you know evil reason too right so i
think it's about what you bring to it
and i think it's ultimately about how
you practice it
for sure speaking of the words practice
which stoic practice do you find most
useful
in life i mean journaling certainly
you know and and i have a somewhat
expanded version of journaling i mean i
journal but then
to me writing about stoicism is even my
books as a form of sort of journaling
and discussion and
and so i think you know the stoics were
writers
almost all of them were writers uh
and it was a tradition that survives to
us because of the writing
so i think writing about it is a big one
um
probably memento mori is the is this the
kind of the most profound uh for the
stoics you know
uh there's no theme probably that in the
stoic works
more prevalent than the reality and
inevitability of death and
that that's something i try to think a
lot about as well yeah it's a great way
to start the day isn't it
um one of the yeah uh i wanted to ask i
wanted to ask you this for a long time
um i heard you speaking to greg mcewen
about this recently past modern wisdom
guest and wonderful guy
um how do you balance the desire for
excellence
with not being too hard on yourself
yeah it's uh it's tough i was thinking
about this
last night i've been burned out a little
bit
and i was like why am i you know why am
i feeling this way and it's like oh wait
first off it's a pandemic i have not had
a break
since march i've got two kids at home
uh no child care and you know i'm
two-thirds of the way through like my
next book and it's like oh [ __ ] that's
why i feel burned out
i'm literally burning the candle at both
ends right like
like uh that's why i feel that way so i
think
part part of the way you have to do it
you have to realize that like you're not
a machine or
if you are a machine you have to take
care of it you know like
you have to keep you have to you know
keep it in in if to
take good care of it um but but i think
uh the the what i've really worked on
more is just becoming more and more
detached
from results so like excellence like on
this book
excellence is like what does it look
like on the page
did i get there you know did i succeed
within
the you know the the bounds of what
was conceivable for that project and
like
i mean i'm sure my publisher doesn't
want to hear a bit here but i really
don't give a [ __ ] how it does do you
know what i mean like it won't
it won't affect it it could it could
certainly affect the bottom line for me
but it doesn't affect
my day-to-day perceptions of myself or
the project
because like i know it's good i know
what it does what that it's supposed to
do
and i know that for the people who will
read it it will do that for them
and so i think i you know this is
something harder for me to understand in
my career but like
you really as you do get closer to
mastery of something
and and close can be relative i just
mean as you get closer from
you know complete hack to you know
yeah um yeah as you get on as you get
there
you you become less obsessed with
results or you become less obsessed with
what other people
define those results as
it's far easier to transcend
to fulfill our material desires than it
is to transcend them
is a quote that i've been thinking about
a lot this year what does that mean
so the fact that it's much easier for
you to drive around in a bashed up
pickup truck if your last car was a
ferrari
i think that there are i wonder whether
ryan holiday the no times best-selling
author
would be able to be as uh equanimous
about the success of his next book sure
you know yeah no i i know exactly what
you mean i think about this
uh like with my parents like would my
parents
like my parents are proud and happy with
my career
if i was just as fulfilled and happy
with it
but was a starving artist would they be
able to
understand it the same way probably not
and and i'm not sure i would be able to
actually get there either right so
yeah there's a there's a pla it's like
when you win a super bowl
you can go like it's it's not whether
you win or lose it's how you play you
know that that it's like it's much
easier to get there
at the same time one of the reasons
you're
able to get there is because now you
know
yeah you know what i mean like when when
what's been weird for me is my books
have been successful but but for a long
time
they were successful but without so they
had the impact like i
they were selling they were reaching
people i was hearing
the people that it reached and what they
were able to do and yet
some of the external markers of success
were lagging indicators for me
so like the obstacle is the way had sold
probably 600 000 copies before it hit a
single bestseller list
right i it was i think stillness is the
key was my ninth book maybe my tenth
book i don't remember but the point is
that was my first not just my first uh
new that was my first new york times
bestseller period
under my own name i'd ghost written
books that it did but that was like the
first time my books
hit the bestsellers and it debuted at
number one which is great but then like
two weeks later you know donald trump
jr's book hit
the best took the number one spot and
and it was revealed that he cheated his
way on the list
right so like you i think what that was
illustrated for me in a lot of ways one
that
you know critical or you know uh
verifiable success external success in
that sense
is not the same as actual success
and then also that actually getting
those markers
winning those awards or getting that
recognition or whatever
um it's a lot more anticlimactic than
you would think
right and that it doesn't doesn't really
solve your problems it doesn't really
so i think there's a jim carrey quote
where he's like i wish everyone could be
rich and famous so they realize
that it doesn't mean anything now that's
kind of like the ultimate privileged
thing to say
and like it's you know preposterous or
whatever but it but there is an element
of truth in it and that like
when you actually get the things that
you think you wanted
you realize that they were never
capable of giving you what you thought
you wanted
the sad fact is that it's so hard to
internalize that lesson
without having been like imagining the
view of the mountain
mindfully you're there you can feel the
wind on your face but
if you haven't gone to the top there's
always that you know we hate open loops
there's zeigarnik effect humans hate
open loops and
i think a lot of these um unfulfilled
desires
which is one of the reasons that i've
been trying to advocate to my friends
and
everyone that listens for a long time to
try and front load the discomfort
and the socialized objective measures of
success in life
because as far as i'm concerned the
sooner that you can do that and tick
that box
the sooner you can get onto what
actually matters because over time you
see
your grandparents you know they don't
care about the car that they drive they
don't care about the brand of shoes that
they wear
so you know that's the trajectory that
you're on everyone's on this same
trajectory that's where you're going to
end up because every
grandparent kind of doesn't give a [ __ ]
and it's kind of a little bit
disgruntled and kind of just wants to
spend time with the family
that's where you're going to end up so
front load the stuff that you can
do and get it out the way no that's
that's totally right when they do
studies like old people tend to
associate
happiness with contentment young people
with achievement and
obviously you need a certain amount of
achievement to be content or you know
you you live under a bridge somewhere
probably but
but but yeah front loading is important
and then
and then i think where people can
somewhat can be a little blase about it
go oh
you know you you only know that you're
only saying it doesn't matter because
yeah you have the success of being a
number one bestseller
so the reality is life is constantly
teaching us that lesson it's like
you know you thought hey if i can get
the you know if i can get the
the popular girl to go out with me then
i'll feel good about myself i won't feel
like a you know
i won't feel like a loser and then you
got it and it turned out actually she
was awful and
you know it wasn't that awesome yeah or
whatever it is like
you you are constantly being taught that
lesson and then we
plug our ears and close our eyes to the
message so like
you know they're i was saying about
super bowl plenty of people
have been there like they made it to the
top of the mountain
and they won a super bowl and it was
anti-climactic
and they didn't it didn't trigger
self-awareness
what it triggered in them was the
idea that oh it's i have to win
back-to-back super bowls right like oh
no you're going in the wrong direction
right because people will go oh i
i if you do it once it doesn't feel good
because it could be a fluke you have to
you have to prove you know what i mean
like the dose wasn't high enough yeah
yeah the mind in in insidiously
manages to always find a way to motivate
us to go forward and we can understand
why
from an evolutionary standpoint this is
is perfectly logical
but from an individual standpoint wants
to be happy it's a recipe for misery
i don't know if you're familiar with
robert wright's book why buddhism is
true
yeah yes i love his evolution books too
he wrote a great book called the moral
animal
dude everyone that's listening there we
go that's moral animal bingo for you
today
um i i must talk about that book every
single podcast and thankfully you've
brought it up on this one so i don't
need to
okay in that he talks about the um
translation of life is suffering
and the word is dukkha but some scholars
can test that it's not
suffering but unsatisfactoriness
holy [ __ ] man when i read that i just
thought it fits in
so neatly with everything that we know
about hedonic adaptation
and the present self versus the
remembering self
like it was just i love when things fall
together like that
um i thought it was a really beautiful
idea so i've got
two quick things that i want to go
through one of them relates to what we
were just talking about and it's an idea
i've been playing around with
since a conversation i had a couple of
weeks ago i'm a big fan
of trying to lead a consciously designed
life
i want to step into my programming as
much as possible i don't want to be
constrained by societal norms or genetic
predisposition or the way that i
deal with past traumas or any of that i
want to be
as conscious as i can with the actions
and the thoughts and the words that i do
but i had a conversation with a guy
called justin tosi he's a philosopher
from the university of texas tech
and he um advocated instinct a lot more
he was like dude you you have to
remember
that your body does an awful lot
correctly
unconsciously and it actually gave a
good counterpoint to this kind of
um super consciously designed life
riff that i've been on for probably the
last 18 months and has given me
a second's pause to think actually hang
on
should i have should i be consciously
looking to design
every single action that i can should i
be second guessing
all of my uh uh choices and virtues what
do you think the the stoics would say
about that what do you say well
this is actually a big debate amongst
the stoics and early on it's kind of a
hard fork between
zeno and clianthes and then one of the
other early stokes a guy named aristo
and you know the early stokes and some
of the later stokes were really
interested in like precepts like
great quotes reminders this is what the
writing was all about do this don't do
that think about this think about that
and he was like that's not how it works
you have to
do the reading do the work but he says
the wise man
knows you know that it it that a lot of
this comes
ultimately from a place of intuition and
instinct
um i i kind of am a you know
split the difference kind of a thing i
think like look if you're
if you're constantly referring to some
sort of rule book
you know if you're a slave to like a set
of constraints or systems you're
probably
you know not as fluid and and you know
free-flowing as you ought to be
at the same time you know some of our
instincts are bad
you know and so i i i think it's kind of
a mix
between the two i like making it kind of
a muscle memory that you can rely on at
the same time
i think it's so easy to go astray that
it's really important to have reminders
like my desk and
the walls of my office are covered in
pictures and quotes and
statues and and you know i carry these
challenge coins in my pocket
i i the reminders are really really
helpful to me
i get that i'm uh i'm just about to pull
up one of my favorite
quotes from uh confucius and it's um
part of an article that i found through
kyle eschenroder
who is this wonderful writer i brought
him on the podcast i loved i loved his
okay kyle's just i mean what a guy um
so he says in the early stages of
training an aspiring confucian gentleman
needs to memorize entire shelves of
archaic texts
learn the precise angle at which to bow
and learn the lengths of steps with
which he is to enter a room
his sitting mat must always be perfectly
straight all of this rigor and restraint
however
is ultimately aimed at producing a
cultivated but nonetheless genuine form
of spontaneity
indeed the process of training is not
considered complete until the individual
has passed completely beyond the need
for thought or effort
yeah that's right and i think that what
is that term like sprezzatura or
whatever
it that the highest form is
effortlessness
and i think that that's where you're
trying to get and that's that's what all
the efforts are aimed at that sort of
effortlessness
final question what area are you hoping
to improve on most
over the next year that's a good
question i think
as always temper uh you know temper and
uh you know i never i feel like i'm
never proud that i've lost my temper i
find that it i you know i get angry or
more than i need
not a lot i just i i you know things
piss
piss me off as they do i think
you know to just to sort of be able to
flow more naturally to things and not
you know the stokes talk like why are
you asking why
you know it just it is what it is right
i think getting there is a big one and
then
i think the thing i we're talking about
effortlessness the thing i struggle with
is
and obviously that's why i wrote a book
on it but you know the ability to not
do is in some cases the hardest thing to
do
right and and you know i'll find myself
you know things have been easy or clean
or simple
and then the next thing i know i'm in
the middle of something and and when i
really trace back how that happened
you know i invited myself into that
right i sought it out
it didn't uh it's not like this thing
dropped in my lap right and so
i think one of the things i've taken
from the pandemic is just
how much less i need and how much
simpler and better life is when there's
less going on
uh but but maintaining that is really
difficult and
it's like you cut out drinking and then
the next thing you know you're smoking
and then you cut out smoking
you know whatever you know like uh it's
sort of like whack-a-mole with the
with our inability to sit quietly in a
room alone
life is unsatisfactoriness man that's
sadly
what it is uh ryan i've adored today
thank you so much for coming on man
lives of the stoics will be linked in
the show notes below
where else do you want to direct people
dailystoic.com yeah
and then we do an email every day about
stoicism
at daily stoic and then youtube videos
at youtube.com
daily stoic go and check them out linked
in the show notes below
ryan i uh i'm gonna have to get you back
online whenever this next book
book is out wherever you two thirds of
the way through we're gonna have to get
you back
yeah and hopefully my internet
connection will be better next time that
would be
wonderful for now man thank you so much
i appreciate it